what's up guys lunch money time while
Wall Street is trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right I've got the beautiful and
intelligent miss Polina Marin over here
the last day that we have to do this
remotely what's going on over there
today there's no lag so we're not gonna
talk over each other we're getting
smarter we're getting smarter what was
the first topic so unemployment
it's the devastation is has reached
Great Depression moguls what do you what
do you think yes so two things so
yesterday we talked about unemployment
in the last week is over 33 million
people have filed for new unemployment
claims in the last seven weeks now what
the numbers that came out today were
April's numbers so they're showing that
20 million Americans a little over 20
million are now kind of sustainably on
unemployment so it wasn't just a
one-time file for the week it's actually
they're on unemployment that means that
the unemployment number has jumped up to
over 14 percent right if you go back
remember about 15 percent was this the
third year of the Great Depression so so
very the third year so in the Great
Depression basically what happened was
in 1929 they were at 3.1 percent they
jumped the next year to over 8% and then
the third year in 1931 they jumped to
over 15 percent what we've seen here is
in February we were at 3.5% we then
jumped to in March over 4% almost 5% now
we've jumped to over 14% but there's a
catch there's always a catch when
there's data so one of the things that
came out recently is in a JP Morgan note
is that over 6 million people are not
being counted as unemployed instead
they're being counted as having left the
workforce so those people were being
counted as unemployed you would then
have over 18 percent well why would they
be counted if they're unemployed given
that they you said they're they're
retired or they're they're just
the workforce well so basically they get
retired they say they're not looking for
work anymore right all these different
things the problem with that component
of it is they actually may not be
looking for work right they actually may
be retiring but what it doesn't do is it
doesn't give us a clear picture if you
don't include them of the job
destruction that's happened over the
last couple of weeks right and so again
look at the end of the day this is
really really bad regardless of how you
account 14% 18% whatever it is those are
the official numbers and of course then
you add in freelancers gig workers
self-employed the situation is really
bad and the last thing I'll say on this
is just you know I don't know if you see
them clean up but there's more and more
reports of restaurants in New York City
that aren't coming back bars that aren't
coming back right and people just
throwing their hands up and say listen
we're done
right in two months I mean who can
survive at this point this is just even
with the relief most of them don't have
the capital base to do it right and so
what it ends up highlighting again if
you go back is how many of these
companies are coming back how many of
these small businesses small businesses
make up 50% of all jobs in the United
States and if let's say 20% don't come
back that means that on average 10% of
the jobs aren't coming back so even if
we reopen the economy's we get people
back to work 10% the jobs just aren't
going to be there which is gonna be a
big issue right yeah absolutely
all right what's the next topic okay
Paul a billionaire is getting into
Bitcoin Paul Tudor Jones thinks Bitcoin
could be the fastest horse in the
markets do you know who Paul Tudor Jones
is what I do he's one guy yeah he's an
absolute legend on Wall Street
he's been very early in a lot of asset
classes been doing this for a long time
he's worth over five billion dollars and
his whole thing was in 2017 he traded
around in Bitcoin but just use it as a
trading you know asset and I think he
actually doubled his money doubled some
of the money that he put in so he had a
good experience but just said look you
know this isn't actually something that
I'm interested in
now comes you know 2020 and he
calculates that over four trillion
dollars has been printed since February
central banks around the world and he's
worried about inflation and so he went
he looked at all these different
inflation hedge assets
he said Bitcoin to him is going to be
the winner he thinks it will appreciate
the most and will provide the most
protection and so he's gonna take a
single-digit percentage probably
somewhere between two to five percent of
his fund and he's gonna put it into
Bitcoin and get exposure to it one it's
just interesting that somebody who's so
you know kind of held in high regard on
Wall Street and so much part of like the
old boys club publicly saying this and
doing this and I think that's a big
validation it gives a lot of people kind
of career cover now if you're at another
hedge fund you can go ahead and look at
this and possibly do it because you
could always points out well Paul Tudor
Jones did it that's what I was gonna ask
you Paul isn't exactly like an anarchist
or the type of person you think when you
think Bitcoin do you think that this
will bring more people from Wall Street
down to the lunch money level so he
actually says in the note and I forget
the exact language but he basically says
something like I'm not a crypto nut
right saying like look like exactly what
you're saying right it's just I'm just
looking at this as rationally as
possible and I think that this is
important it definitely will give a lot
of people permission to now talk about
this to potentially invest in it and go
look at it and it goes back to what
we've been talking for weeks now there's
lots of money printing going on
inflation is likely to hit at some point
in the future and if you have sound
money principles whether it's gold or
Bitcoin you're likely to be protected so
it's great to see somebody doing that
you know that comes kind of from the old
Wall Street world do we think this is
why Bitcoin hit 10k um I don't know if
like that there's two schools of thought
here right one it well three one is just
the macroeconomic backdrop obviously
things are getting worse people want
Bitcoin whether it's Paul Tudor Jones or
you know average Joe or sue no problem
they're just buying the assets a fixed
supply price goes up to is yesterday
when the news got announced within the
next two hours there was a pretty big
jump in price a couple hundred bucks so
that's kind of like the Paul Tudor Jones
effect if you will and then third is the
have
is coming right so the bitcoin having is
gonna happen on very early Tuesday
morning and people are speculating
around that right so it's kind of a
convolution of all these things can you
can you help the people understand this
and put an end to the debate is it
having or happening what do you say
I see happy that's what I say too I know
what a happening is but I think that the
happening use is the way that it was
said originally and then over time
people were like wait a minute that
sounds pretty dumb and they started use
having and now there's I don't know 50
50 happening having but definitely
having I think is becoming more popular
and more accepted and really the people
who started out saying happening right
that they're kind of stuck in their ways
if you will but but even once right I
don't think either one is wrong sorry I
didn't mean to go down this rabbit hole
it's a controversial debate in the in
the Bitcoin world you want to know you
want to hear something really
interesting that I looked up this
morning what I'll ask you to quiz
questions the first is what do you think
the price appreciation of Bitcoin has
been since the last happening are we
talking percentages no just actual like
what do you think the Earlham answer
this what do you think the price was at
the last tapping was four years ago
right yes like 4k no it was six hundred
and seventy dollars give or take oh wow
so it's gone up 15 X since the last tab
15 X and four years now the hash rate is
how much computing power securing the
network what how many multiples has it
increased since 2016 3 X 100x what do
you think it is 14 X 78 X and Salinas so
it's just it just is more data point
suggesting like it's growing people are
buying into it both psychologically and
financially all right what's next so
guess who Elon Musk
doesn't like of all the people who
Warren Buffett not surprising do you
know why he doesn't like her
know why so Elon Musk went on Joe
Rogan's podcast again this time they did
not smoke weed but they did talk about
various things including how Elon Musk
is not the biggest fan of Warren Buffett
and the reason is because Warren he says
he warned as a capital allocator and he
said he reads a lot of annual reports of
companies all the accounts all the
account and it's pretty boring honestly
when he's trying to figure out it's just
Coke or Pepsi deserve more capital he
thinks that's boring he thinks you know
but here's what I here's what I think I
think that Elon is just a little salty
cuz we're Buffett is fifth in the world
on the Bloomberg billionaires index and
musk is 22nd I'd be salty too you think
that he's mad because Warren Buffett's
richer than him yes maybe it's possible
for sugar so musk is basically saying
Warren is a capital allocator I am
building you know I'm a builder is he
wrong um ask you this which job is
harder I don't know I think well yeah I
feel like Musk's whatever the hell he's
doing is really difficult but also
Buffett like how do you know if Coke or
Pepsi deserves more capital well there's
a lot of people over the last decade or
20 years who have beaten Buffett's
returns including the S&P fact that's
definitely a fact look he's one of the
best investors in the world right and it
has been for a very long time so taking
nothing away from Warren Buffett but it
is much easier for somebody sitting at
home to be a capital allocator than it
to be a builder right and obviously if
you look at something what like what
Elon Musk has done where he literally
really lands rockets right and he's now
got one of the old he's got the only
American car company like last hundred
years that has survived right and and so
it's just these are very very hard
things to do takes nothing away from
Buffett but I think must
it sounds like is very much build
reverse capital allocator yeah and of
course the Builder is gonna think the
capital allocators boring right so
that's not surprising I also think that
there's an element if I remember
correctly Buffett said some things
recently that he would not be buying
Tesla stock wouldn't be wouldn't be
reasonably salty yeah exactly well and
also you named your kid after our robots
oh wait I saw this meme I don't know if
it's real so fact check this but
basically like they broke it down by how
each thing sounds it broke down into
Kyle all of this for a Kyle it's so
funny the the other thing I saw was
somebody was saying what a weird world
we live in where Elon Musk basically has
to go on Joe Rogan so we can have a
sanity check after he fires off a couple
crazy tweets right like from like a PR
standpoint he said all those huh you
know a couple days ago then within a
week he's on Joe Rogan and they have an
in-depth discussion so everyone can see
that musk is okay what what's next so
Frontier Airlines have you ever taken
off Frontier flight once never again I
don't think I have yeah it's an expiry
but worse oh that's the one we're in
like they charge you for like the seat
you know they charge you for the oxygen
while you're sitting in the seat they're
like hey you want to breathe our air
you're no problem that'll be $20 oh you
want an armrest that didn't come with
your seat that's another $20 do you
remember when we went to Iceland that
was a whole thing
okay so Frontier Airlines will soon
become the first US carrier to check
passengers temperatures before allowing
people to get on board so basically if
you're checking in and you have a
temperature if they have a fever so over
a hundred Fahrenheit you can't get on
yeah I mean look there's two schools of
thought one is that they're starting to
over
each on civil liberties and personal
freedoms you know take for example the
Patriot Act and all the TSA stuff after
2001 now they basically search you they
literally Pat you down they take an
x-ray of your body you know all that
kind of stuff
on the name of safety right so there's a
balance there between you know two
different groups of thought but then the
other argument is that you should be a
libertarian argument right which is
basically you should be allowed to do
whatever you want as long as you don't
hurt anybody else
right but the argument could be if you
get on the plane with a temperature
you're hurting somebody else right and
so it's a I don't know these are complex
topics that have no right or wrong
answer and that there's kind of
operating in the gray area and you know
look at the end of the day I don't think
a lot of people are gonna start flying
right away and so it'll be interesting
to see is this gonna be a permanent
solution or is this going to be you know
how we're gonna do it for six months and
then we'll go back to the way we used to
do it it's interesting that it's
frontier that's during this it's not
like Delta or United or American
frontiers on the frontier they want to
charge you for something extra they
might Margie they might charge you for
the test right the other way home the
other thing too is uh would you get on a
plane within the next six weeks if you
knew that everyone was gonna get tested
but would it make you more confident hmm
so we we had this conversation I don't
want to get on a plane right now just
for various things but I don't know I
guess it would but I wouldn't want to be
tested that make sense you want to get
on the plane and and not get tested
no like like I like I would feel more
confident flying if I knew nobody had a
fever on the flight but I don't like the
idea of them testing people yeah I'm
with you
but they got a test to find it right all
right what's next hey by the way don't
think I didn't notice your 70s disco
outfit on there
go yeah I see it's like meeting with the
shining ball going around the disco ball
and going off the lights just hit us
with like one of these little disco
moves exactly good um what am I going
ahead for guys you can't see the topics
right now so I'm in full control come on
come on come on so there's a there's a
picture that you sent me it says great
picture of what a virtual classroom can
look like when it meets the non virtual
world and it's a little girl doing her
homework at her parents like restaurant
yeah it looks I don't know where the
photo is from so people will definitely
figure it out but it looks like it's
somewhere in Asia and it looks like it's
kind of not like a street vendor but
definitely like a shop where there might
not be any seating so you kind of walk
right into the counter and they're
serving some sort of food and she's
sitting under the counter it has a
laptop out and she's doing her classroom
while her parents are serving customers
and so you know there's two pieces some
people on the internet are upset by the
photo they're like wow that's so sad
that girl is literally stuck at a
restaurant doing it then there's a whole
other group of people who are basically
saying look how optimistic does this
make you that now this girl who might
not have had access to education can now
get access to education simply with a
laptop and a Wi-Fi you know while she's
at her parents restaurant
what do you was camp are you in I like
that she can do that I like that the
power of technology has gotten us so far
you're in the optimist camp I'm an
optimist like she can she can do
anything she wants pinchy yes all right
I'm on board
look technology makes the world better
right yes it can be used for bad or
nefarious things but I definitely agree
that it makes it better for the most
part and we should encourage this stuff
am I good for her she's learning
everyone leave her alone stop trying to
you know politicize her on the internet
politicize oh I'm sure they are come on
if there's a photo on the internet it's
definitely getting politicized okay
all right come on
we all get a couple minutes left what
else what else you got well it's
Mother's Day on Sunday and it's also
lunch money time so we we heard a rumor
we've been getting information that
there are a lot of moms who are watching
this show Polina and I happy Mother's
Day to all of you we know who some of
you are they're not our mothers there
are actually other people's Mother's but
one we appreciate you guys watching and
two there are probably many many other
moms that are out there so happy
Mother's Day Polina how do you say that
in Bulgarian Oh
oh my god put her on the spot yes come
with their pitch floor yeah Oh No why is
it hard oh just think oh so me must it's
hard because mothers am bulgaria is
March 8th which is like International
Women's Day and that's when they
celebrate it you guys have a different
one that's I could think of it why do
you guys have different holidays in the
rest of us no you have different
holidays and in lunch money which we
make people do take the URL share it on
social media use the hashtag lunch money
and any URL it doesn't have to be this
URL or this lunch money
yeah can we in any show and use hashtag
lunch money and tell us one thing you
learned this week
no jokes what did you learn people are
gonna have jokes
um and then guys I had something funny
to say there and I didn't say cuz I want
to be nice today I've been on Nick talk
and I've been on tic TOCs like magic
trick
tick tock oh man I have so many things
to show you when you come back you know
you're on magic to choke magic trick
tick tock it exists oh my god it's so
cool before people are really smart and
funny in our guy
a hundred dollars we're gonna give $100
this Friday to whoever shares weather
videos from the week use hashtag lunch
money tell us one thing you learned
we'll get some people some lunch money
and well while she's trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right we appreciate you guys
watching thanks for putting up with all
of Plymouth bad dad jokes and we will
talk to you guys on Monday